[Music]
all right Chris I was talking to Nvidia
yesterday as you do that's to me and mr.
Nvidia were just bumped into each other
to chat um but it's not far wide what
what is important is they offhandedly
just showed me this thing that they had
been working on that I really hadn't
heard of it's called sharing shouldn't
share like you hadn't heard of sharing
handy I know right because they already
have shadowplay and they'd broadcast
stuff and they've been doing that for a
while but they have this new thing that
basically it just shares to one person I
know using Chrome using a plug-in in
Chrome oh and did I mention that that
one person you share with can play your
game over the Internet this you're
describing this to me earlier before we
actually did it and it's it sounded
really weird and yonkers but basically
what happened was you started up your
game yup you started sharing I got an
email that was like your buddy wants to
play a game with you I was like cool it
opened up a new window in Chrome and
there all the sudden I was seeing the
gameplay I like you're like what I like
no I did rest waz D and Geralt was all
of a sudden running around I moved my
mouse around it was going all crazy I
was controlling the game that you were
running on your computer you know
through my Chrome browser yeah it could
be on any PC like I was running on the
on my pretty good gaming PC of the GTX
970 and then it broadcasted it out and
it gives you a link or you can just
directly email somebody and then they
can play on any Chrome browser it could
be a Mac you know the caveat being we're
on the same sort of network here within
our office but it responded with
alacrity it was like I was playing and
you know I was in the menus I was out of
the menu I was moving around as Geralt
and it was a very comfortable playing
experience it was awesome except for
when we both tried to do things that got
a little weird occasionally but also it
opens up to different plate ways to play
like if you want to play with a loved
one or a friend over the internet do it
do quests and like pick and choose if
they're out of town or something this do
it this way yeah this is just as kind of
like the passing the controller thing
that Nintendo sort of dabbled with in
certain games but like you're you're
basically just playing it on the couch
with them like letting them do their
thing
but you're both your computer wherever
the hell you each are yeah and
hey here's the thing they are basically
you could even just like boot up the
game share it and then walk away and
then like all of a sudden I'm playing
this game that I have not paid for and I
maybe don't even have a computer that
can run but I'm playing it as if I own
it
yeah it's a little bit mind-blowing I
can't imagine publishers are gonna be
too stoked about this it just seems so
open how could they it's basically like
hey we sold one copy of our game this
person can share with however many
people they want one at a time though so
I guess there is that
yeah it's slightly limited you can also
play as if you were their co-op yeah two
player controller stuff because we
played rocket lead split-screen with
someone on a Mac and then we played
internet Laura Croft and the Temple of
Osiris yeah as if we were doing local
co-op yeah and it was just the local
co-op experience except one of us did
not have to have the game at all no you
don't have to have a game or a system
that even runs the game you got a
browser you get a good internet
connection it's a little staggering to
think about how it just should be so
easy it seems so easy it was really easy
and you can download this stuff it's in
early access beta uh you just you know
Google that on and it'll come up in
videos website Oh people say hey you
want download this early access beta
geforce experience software and there it
is you're ready to go and we're talking
about playing with friends but you can
also talk about you know playing with
people you meet online you know get I've
streaming and being like hey you're in
the chat like every 15 minutes someone
new is gonna hop in it's almost like a
in this that same kind of spirit of like
twitch plays Pokemon like yeah you can
crowdsource a little bit just by like
sending emails to different people and
having them like hop in and do different
stuff so the footage they see will be
limited to I think right now in beta
seven twenty thirty it's still freaking
crazy to think that you could play a
graphical powerhouse like The Witcher 3
over the internet without any semblance
of a gaming PC at all unfortunately like
we tried it with we were just racking
our brains think about all the cool
stuff we could try with didn't quite
work with samurai gonna need hog for
some reason I think it's just the maybe
the way that game is rendered it doesn't
go across maybe that'll be fixed you
know yeah who knows when update
compatibility issues yeah I know from
game to game are a present at this point
in the beta yeah so but it seems to work
on a huge variety of stuff right now
including phantom pain The Witcher
- right I think what else a Pro Evo just
came out and yeah I I can't even imagine
like what people are gonna use with this
or maybe I won't even catch on I don't
know but if you have a gtx card download
and check it out and let us know like
how you plan on using or if you think is
cool enough give it a shot
yeah and yeah to be able to play games
with your friends who like I don't know
they're they're not as into it as you
they don't have that gaming PC oh it's
not out for this system but yes it's out
for Crowell yeah bizarre and wonderful
hopefully babe don't get shut down by
publishers they are definitely gonna get
shut down by publishers
[Music]
you
[Music]